التقلبات المناخيه في الاوينات الاخيره
القات بظلالها ليس على المناطق المعتدله
في العالم فحاسم بل على بلاد الثلج والبرد
ايضا استطيع روسي معروف لدى الجميع لعل
الكثير من الاحداث التاريخيه ومنها قصص
الحرب العالميه الثانيه ارتبطت بالشتاء
والثلوج وقساوه البرد المثير ان الشتاء
روسيا بدايه العام الجاري سجل ارقاما
قياسيا بارتفاع درجات الحراره تابعتها
ارقام بدرجات الحراره المتدنيه ما حول
الشوارع وطرقات المدينه الى باحاتا للتزلج
طالت السكان ووسائل النقل ضيفنا في
الاستوديو اليوم وراثنا العزيز عبد الجواد
الرشد الهارب من صقيع روسيا روسيا الحراره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تلفزيون طبيعي
ياتي الشتاء دون استئذان ياتي محملا
بالامطار والبرد ورهبه الزكام والوضع
يختلف من بلد عربي لاخر لكن في روسيا ياتي
الشتاء هيك يعني يحمل الاذن بالدخول
[موسيقى]
وتملا الاراضي لمده سته اشهر ثمانيه اشهر
الصقيع يضرب كل شيء طب
الجواد من بدايه سنه دافئه هي يعني اكثر
دفئا في تاريخ الارصاد الجويه الى اقل من
30 درجه تحت الصفر شو اللي صار صحيح رقم
قياسي تم تسجيله مع بدايه العام الجديد
هذا الرقم كان يعود الى تاريخ 73 من القرن
الماضي عندما وصل لدرجه الحراره الى اربع
درجات مئويه اربع درجات مئويه في وجود 100
كبيره من الثلوج يذوب تصبح الارض يعني نهر
من المياه يجري على الارض لكن هذه السنه
وصلت درجات الحراره الى 6 درجات بعد ست
درجات خلال يومين هبطت درجات الحراره
اصبحت تصل الى 26 و 28 تحت الصفر لكن
الاحساس بالبرد مع الهواء وصل الى 35 36
درجه تحولت اراضي
موسكو سان بطرسبورغ مدن اخرى الى بحتى
تزلج نصف السياره ما داريت
فرق الدرجه الحراره الكبيره والتوقفت
السيارات عن العمل همم السقوط على الارض
يعني انا حتى كنت من بين الاشخاص اللي
سقطوا على الارض صعب انك تمشي على 20 متر
وتوصل الى المكان دون تو على اليمين او تو
على اليسار يعني الموضوع شبه بالفكاهه
نوعا ما لكنه بالفعل هي هو وضع صعب خاصه
هلا هاي الصوره لما نزلت درجات الحراره
الى مستوى متدني جميع بطاريات الكاميرات
تتوقف عن العمل
والسبيل الوحيد للخروج عبر الهواء مباشره
هو جهاز الهاتف
كاميرا الموبايل شوفي تطور التقني لو ان
ودانا كاميرا الموبايل عم تحمول البرد
والدرجات كبيره وهي احد اللقطات اللي كنت
فيه انا على الهواء سهام
اوووه
طيب هون يعني كميات كبيره
لمده 20 30 ثانيه
المباشر مضطر انت تسحب الميكروفون لانه
ايدك تكون جمدانه
اليوميه اه انت الصبح مضطر في البيت لازم
تكون مهتم شكلك
كويس توصل لعند سيارتك بتلاقيها بهذا
المشهد اكيد تتعرف عليها
واحيانا ما بتفتح السياره مضطره تنظفها
شويه
ما بعرف بشوف لحتى تقدر تطلع الفرشايه
وبقعد عمليه تنظيف السياره تستمر عشر
دقائق 15 دقيقه 20 دقيقه دقيقه
جوعان وصلت للسياره كله بيضه وانا بذكرها
كويس اه بدي افتح الباب صعب حتى يعني كبسه
السياره ما عم تشتغل بلشنا نضيف بالسياره
بايدي واوقعت وقمت اوه بالشنطه قام طلعت
عم ننظف سياره مو سياره
تنظيف سيارات
[موسيقى]